salut c'est jimmy et je suis content de
vous retrouver une fois de plus pour
notre rendez-vous voyages quotidiens sur
la première aujourd'hui je vous emmène
au qatar on parie retrouver stéphane
magdelonnette un martiniquais qui brille
et qui réussit dans le milieu de
l'hôtellerie de luxe savez stéphane bain
très bien on est en plein déconfinement
les choses commencent à aller mieux on
espère que ce sera toujours le cas
je te pose la question à toi qui est
très loin de la martinique au qatar
comment ça se passe au ghana l'atv le
qatar c'est une destination qui fait
rêver quand on parle de vacances alors
moi l'image que j'en ai cédé building
c'est du luxe et c'est vraiment fait les
images qu'on retrouve souvent sur les
réseaux sociaux toi qui vit est ce que
est ce que c'est ça est ce que c'est un
monde
on dit qu'au qatar tout est multiplié
par mille les choses sont gigantissime
le luxe est présent partout c'est ça
quand on y vit la prochaine liée à la
mode sont représentés le secteur de
mobilier et de la finance qui prend de
l'ampleur
donc franchement c'était très bon écoute
ce sera avec plaisir peut-être pas pour
la coupe du monde parce que je suis pas
très foot mais en tout cas pour visiter
ces fameux hôtel dont tu parlais tout à
l'heure et était bien placé pour nous en
parler parce qu'on l'a pas dit mais toi
tu bosses dans l'hôtellerie et dans
l'hôtellerie de luxe un parce que tu
travailles pour une grande chaîne
d'hôtels comme en martinique est parti
de de fort de france se retrouve aussi
loué au qatar a bossé pour un grand
groupe hôtelier c'est une langue ils
sont ensuite à votre consentement au
masters d'hambourg management du luxe
je me suis dit que je devais relever le
défi donc je voulais travailler dans
différents pays
ma progresse qu'à la vérité vous aimiez
a été conçu comme à proposer donc de
participer à l'ouverture de deux hôtels
de luxe et donc j'ai choisi cette option
parce que le concept est plus
intéressant maintenant je suis
supervision
j'imagine que toi qui travaille dans
l'hôtellerie tu nous est alors c'était
un peu compliqué au qatar par rapport
aux combis 19
j'imagine qu'avec ce lancement d'hôtel
qui vient de se faire c'est compliqué
pour vous parce que il ya moins de monde
n'y a pas autant de monde attendu
comment vous en sortez je veux c'est une
situation qui est délicate mais
entre-temps a beaucoup de formations et
puis on essaie en fait en place
différentes règles d'hygiène cette
expérience en soi être considéré comme
négatif mais il faut rebondir moi
j'adhère au principe de résilience
tailleur donc faut toujours aller de
l'avant ne jamais baisser les bras
et voilà et ça ça fait partie des
qualités des concierges d'ailleurs dans
les hôtels s'est toujours trouvé une
solution à tous les problèmes pour voilà
pour pour que les choses avancent donc
c'est un bon état d'esprit et je vois
que tu là et c'est très bien alors le
qatar parce que là tu nous a invité un
tu nous a vendu le truc en disant qu'il
faut qu'on vienne pour la coupe du monde
et tout ça qu'est ce qu'ils diffèrent à
y voir en particulier allons 14 de
l'activité culturelle notamment déguster
les mets typiques
je vais recommander aussi les activités
à sensations fortes telles que des
casseurs safari dans le désert et ben
écoute on viendrait en tout cas pour
faire pour faire ça dans le désert ça va
être très très beau en plus j'imagine
s'est étendu il ya même la possibilité
d'avoir des dîners de monter sur les
chameaux de faire de la luge c'est
quelque chose que je conseille à mike
août
on connaît quelqu'un maintenant qu'est
au qatar et qui bossent en plus d'un
noir l'hôtellerie qui connaît les bons
plans qui saura à quoi nous faire donc
la prochaine fois qu'on vient on regarde
ton numéro on passe un petit coup de fil
et tu nous fais un programme complet de
choses à visiter à voir du côté du qatar
des clients qu'elle serait suffisant des
vip j'avais beau mais très bien et nous
on ramènera pantois des choses du pays
partait ça allait et compagnie écoute
pour le colombo ce n'est pas un souci on
va ramener de la poudre ça on va se
débrouiller pour le chevreuil juste une
bouteille avec modération par contre
pour le flan coco je ne suis pas sûr
stéphane que ça arrive très très frais
m'enfin bon on essaiera merci à toi
c'était vraiment un plaisir d'échanger
âme et on est content de voir que des
martiniquais réussissent à un haut
niveau et on est sûr qu'avec ce que tu
as de martinique est en toi ben tu
l'amènera au qatar et tu pourras le
communiqué aux autres en tout cas merci
pour cette belle rencontre les
dynamiser l'excellence à très bientôt au
bail
voilà c'est une preuve de plus que les
martiniquais bris partout où il se
trouve dans le monde même jusqu'au qatar
merci à vous de nous avoir suivi on se
retrouve très vite sur la première
[Musique]